so each you have over what 200 videos on
your pool I don't know how many of them
are like legit videos or some other
silly things but yeah and we know a lot
of people who you know they're still on
the fence about YouTube and we don't
really know that many actors who have
posted as many clips as you have on
YouTube which is just a wonderful thing
has this been an impact as this had an
impact on your acting career and also
are you a surprise that a lot of actors
still are on the fence about YouTube
yeah you know I never I personally don't
know actors that are on the fence about
this I'm not sure what what that
conversation is but I it kind of is a
no-brainer to me like I don't understand
why you would and I mean it definitely I
know sometimes there's a you know
because the Internet is so easy to to
just access information you know so easy
for people to use that you know some
actors are a little bit more resistant
towards posting things and I think you
have to be smart about what you post you
know for sure because it's forever it's
forever the Internet is forever we all
know that right you know it's it's
always gonna be there but absolutely I
mean you know like I like to think like
I said earlier you're like 30 years ago
40 years ago like where would an actor
be able to post like 10 of their
projects that they've worked on and then
an act as an director or director
somebody comes across and infused these
things you know what I mean you'd have
to hopefully get you get you know hope
that you get called into their office or
that maybe they've seen your work you
know but now I think it's so much easier
to use that to reach these different
people you know maybe they don't have
time to watch you know my you know
co-star scene on Grey's Anatomy you know
I say four lines but I can send them a
link to that particular scene and they
don't you know it's it's not an
hour-long show they'd have to sit
through and then they can see and
they'll watch it you know so absolutely
I mean I think we're in a digital age I
don't know if people realize that but
that's where we are and I think like
that's really important like I think I
mentioned earlier I got a job at Apple
and the only reason I got the job there
was cuz I wanted to learn how to use my
computer to like the fullest ability
like editing my own reels building my
own website you know shooting my own
stuff and like
everything that is on my website you
know my reels all that stuff I've done
my own like I added all my stuff I've
made my own website and I continue to do
that for other people now you know it's
it's it's sort of become a a good job
for me in a way but I knew I was like
well I have this at my fingertips why am
I gonna go spend $400 to have somebody
edit my real one I can do that and learn
and then put my best foot forward you
know and also that teaches me you know
it strengthens strengthens my eye for
what works and what doesn't work you
know and it's just a part of the process
of learning that you know so yeah
absolutely and and just on a simple
silly note you know those YouTube videos
a lot of them when the iPhone first came
out there was an app before it had a
video camera the first iPhone didn't
have a video camera just a regular
camera there was an app that allowed you
to do video through it like it would
sort of you know take you know however
many pictures it is I guess 36 pictures
per second or whatever and you can
record video and I started recording all
these videos around town and I for a
while I was doing all these outdoor
workouts in LA free outdoor workouts and
I would just post about them and talk
like you know like a behind the scenes
thing like oh come check out right in
Canyon where you can you know honey or
whatever for free and I started to make
all these videos and I just started
there called quick videos ki qik was the
app and they've since you know
disappeared cuz now every app does that
but I was making all these little like
sort of behind the scenes documentary
thing of my life it was almost like a
reality television show like I'm just
like oh here's it you know Here I am on
that you know the griddle were eating
this huge pancake or whatever it is you
know and um Eric writer-director you
know of our movies who I worked with on
his student thesis back in a day which
again a free project that I did and like
I said you know there's always stuff
that you can do and you never know where
it leads right well we were friends
obviously I could shooting his student
thesis and he was back in Arkansas you
graduated and he sent me Madison County
and when he first wrote it it's like you
know just your thoughts as an actor like
what what do you think you know any
notes or anything and I gave him notes
and I sent it back whatever and then you
know he was trying to get that made with
a bunch of different producers and they
kept falling through or whatever well
around that time he was in Arkansas you
know working and he was just seeing I
was just posting these quick videos
every day you know
and I guess he was watching them
everyday just like really engaged by
them you know like as silly as they were
he was watching them and Madison County
finally fell through with the last team
that you know that it was and he just
got frustrating he was like you know
what I'm gonna write something that I
can shoot really cheap and just do my
own film I'm tired of waiting you know
for somebody else to say yes you know he
really wanted to do a film and he told
me he was inspired by my videos with the
idea for what was what became hostile
encounter and it was a POV film this was
before like paranormal even was released
like you know now POV films and femme
films are so huge yeah he just came up
with this idea this guy who was kind of
just on the soul-searching thing and you
know sort of recording his whole
experience and you know wrote a feature
around it and he wrote this thing and
then he you know hit me up and he's like
hey would you be interested in coming to
Arkansas for like maybe a week or two
and you know I'll fly you out and put
you up and we'll shoot this movie and he
sent me this script which it was only
like 40 pages because it was very uh I
know it was very experimental in the way
that we shot it and it was more of like
a a guideline you know and he brought up
Daniel was where I went to school with
him and Daniel had a camera gear so he
brought him out to a DP this thing it
was the three of us that was the first
project it was the catalyst for what
became Madison County and you know if it
wasn't for my YouTube videos he wouldn't
have been inspired inspired with that
idea I guess and wouldn't have asked me
to do it and we all three wouldn't have
worked together and then that's how
Madison was born because Daniel was like
he knew he can get money for the movie
and he was like but I want a scene
because I thought he was like he and I
really became friends on the on hostile
encounter and he really loved what Eric
did as an director you know was so
little and he loved my work as an actor
he's like but I want him in the movie
someplace you know and that was sort of
what happened and then here we are what
roadside and then you know brewing our
other things so you know my youtube
channel did put me you know in a
position where it sort of got me a lot
of work you know in a weird way you know
and I have people all the time reference
it and and it works for me you know what
I put it up for and you know there's
silly videos and I never I know some
people are very specific with what they
use their page for like there are
acting related stuff more serious videos
I mean my page is just my page but I
think if anything what it is is a good
representation of Who I am you know and
it's just you know that's kind of what I
use it for it's just you know I don't I
don't really what's the word I don't I
don't really like limit myself to what I
put up there like I think yesterday I
put up two videos and the first time I
did in two days really short things one
was with Wolfie here and then the other
one was uh I don't even remember what
the other one was but you know I just
put him up because they the idea tickled
me and I and I throw it up and I just
like to share it so you know it's it's
just a fun thing for me to have so
actors put up more than just your reel
yeah absolutely yeah I mean put up with
you but you like I mean I think when
we're casting people I mean you know
people can read material yeah but like I
want to see you you know and that's
something we always hear and I get it
from feedback all the time people act
you know cast directors are like we just
want to see your flavor bring your your
person to this cuz you know there's
gonna be 30 people who can read this on
the page excellent but what makes them
stand apart is like you know or stand
out of the crowd is like which one we
really feel like you know we get the
most rum and sometimes that's not like
an actual feeling or a thought but like
there's a reason why the people usually
are on set you know everybody we paid
for Madison County we're also like the
coolest people that had come in for the
part they were just we just you know
sometimes it's just like an energy and a
chemistry thing we're just thing they
walk in you're like this person's cool
cool like I hope they do a good job with
the read you know if they can get the
words down we're kind of in business and
that's kind of what happened you know a
lot of the people were just great people
in the room you know so I think YouTube
is a great you know way to do that
without being in you know intrusive you
know what I mean like if they find it
then they can watch I'm not forcing it
down anybody's throat you know they want
to watch my YouTube page they could do
it and and like I said I think I think
the day people kind of get a sense of
who I am at least it's my personality
you know and and again I think that
that's kind of you know we want to
relate to people so you know I think I
think that that's a fun way to do it
you